Fans of the villain-slash-occasional antihero
Deathstroke are in for a treat when they catch
him in Justice League in theaters.
Joe Manganiello, who plays Deathstroke, has
put together a pretty respectable résumé
over his roughly two decades in the film business,
but he's not quite a household name just yet.
Here are a few reasons he looks so familiar.
Spider-Man
In 2002's Spider-Man, Manganiello played infamous
bully Eugene "Flash" Thompson.
He's horrible to Peter Parker at every opportunity,
to the point where you can't help but cheer
when he finally gets what's coming to him
in the form of Peter's first spider-powered
beatdown.
"I like you so much I wish you had landed
that punch on Tobey Maguire."
How I Met Your Mother
The years after Spider-Man were pretty lean
for Manganiello, who's been open about the
difficulties that followed his first big break.
But eventually he landed a recurring role
on the hit sitcom How I Met Your Mother, joining
the cast in 2006 as Brad, an old law school
friend of Jason Segel's character Marshall.
Brad appeared in seven episodes, and took
on a slightly more antagonistic role in later
seasons, causing drama with both Marshall
and Neil Patrick Harris' character Barney.
One Tree Hill
Between 2008 and 2010, CW melodrama One Tree
Hill gave Manganiello his most significant
TV role up to that point.
He joined the show as Owen, a bar manager
who strikes up a romance with series star
Sophia Bush's character Brooke, and appeared
in twelve episodes over the course of three
seasons.
True Blood
Manganiello next appeared as Alcide, a hunky
werewolf who showed up in the third season
of HBO's vampire drama True Blood.
Alcide is a fan-favorite character from the
books that inspired the show, and Manganiello
nailed it in 42 episodes, thanks to his natural
nice-guy charm and, well, what he looks like
without a shirt.
"Yes.
This is not news to anyone."
White Collar
Season three of the USA Network's White Collar
saw Manganiello sign on for a one-episode
guest appearance, which features him in an
antagonistic role as Ben, the neighbor of
series regular Tiffani Thiessen's character
Elizabeth.
It was the first time in a while Manganiello
played a full-fledged villain — experience
that would come in handy a few years later
when he landed the role of Deathstroke.
Magic Mike
Manganiello's combination of charm and killer
physique clearly got him the right kind of
attention from director Steven Soderbergh,
who cast him in a memorable supporting role
in his 2012 smash hit dramedy Magic Mike.
Manganiello appears in the film as a heartthrob
dancer with… a memorable name.
His go-to costume?
A classic fireman getup.
Funny enough, he almost didn't take the role
— and it was Chris Rock, of all people,
who convinced him to do it.
"And I turned to Chris and I said, 'If I don't
get a shirt on soon, every guy in the world's
gonna hate my guts.'
And Chris said, 'Man, they're gonna hate your
guts anyway."
Sabotage
End of Watch director David Ayer cast Manganiello
in Sabotage, starring Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Manganiello plays Grinder, a character mostly
recognizable due to his distinct cornrows.
Sabotage didn't go over too well with critics
and was ultimately a box office failure, but
it does feature some killer action sequences
and lots of big guys blowing stuff up — which
is kind of all you want from a movie like
this.
Magic Mike XXL
Richie returned in the 2015 followup to Magic
Mike, coyly titled Magic Mike XXL.
With the original film's Alex Pettyfer and
Matthew McConaughey not returning for the
sequel, Manganiello saw a significantly larger
amount of screen time in this one.
Richie is also the centerpiece of what is
almost indisputably the highlight of the film,
when he performs an impromptu striptease set
to "I Want it That Way" by the Backstreet
Boys right in the middle of the empty minimart.
"How much for the Cheetos and water?"
Pee-wee's Big Holiday
Manganiello appeared in another hilarious
role soon after the Magic Mike sequel, playing
a fictionalized version of himself in 2016's
Pee-wee's Big Holiday.
Unlike many cameo roles in which celebs play
themselves, Manganiello is actually a pretty
central character over the course of the movie.
Manganiello plays himself as a perfect caricature—over-the-top
macho but quietly still a goofy little kid
at heart.
"Thanks, I appreciate that."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!